so i've got something i've kind of had
rolling around in my head for years now
and i think i finally need to get it off
my chest we teach poi wrong hey there
drex here from drexfactor poi sharing
with you the love of poi spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and brain
and
i have a few words to say about how we
teach the art and the impact that that
has on the people who learn it when i
first learned how to spend poi back in
2008 and again when i started teaching
it two years later using the same
methods and resources that i'd used
myself
i started to notice a frequent set of
problems emerging that held back both me
and my students
and i have some ideas on how to fix them
before we dive in i just want to give a
quick shout out to the friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroterra light toys spin balls
and ultra poi for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these amazing
businesses and what they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that i've got
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to non-business
friends of the channel johnny howard les
machinski and becca beckham thank you
all so very much for your support for my
work and my mission
now it does have to be said from the
jump that there's no single accepted way
to teach poi out there but there's
absolutely a kind of canon that many if
not most people go through when they
learn the prop it tends to start with
people learning plane control exercises
and then graduating to weaves
butterflies windmills and more
and these are all great tricks and
things to learn but i think they also
come with some problems built in that
i'd like to dive into and work to fix
also if you're new here please make sure
to subscribe for more content around poi
spinning and flow arts i post regular
tutorials combos reviews and even video
essays on the culture around poi and
flow so what's wrong with how we
traditionally learn poi
well stop me if any of this sounds
familiar to you you've just gotten into
spinning poi and maybe you've learned a
few tricks or techniques from your
friends you go to learn some more tricks
online and quickly discover it's
impossible to wrap your head around all
of the things out there
you find some tricks you think are
really cool but the learning curve for
them is nearly impossible or you
discover months down the line that there
was something you missed learning early
on that seems obvious to the people
around you now you've got to go back and
learn it
bomber or you learned your butterflies
and weaves early on like most people and
you've just discovered the world of
flowers and hybrids so cool
but you're so used to tucking your arms
close to you that you've got the
accursed t-rex arms and worse you're not
in control of when you spend the poi so
you have to unlearn a whole bunch of
your early techniques and finally you
learned each trick in isolation and
never learn good techniques for
transitioning between them you'd love to
be able to flow but you just have no
idea how all these different things
connect together much less how to move
or dance with them if you fit into any
of these categories you're in good
company i did too i've taught countless
other people over the years who've run
into these problems too
and i think there's a better way so
here's my goal
i want to create an online course that
is built around a few key priorities
number one create an intuitive structure
x trick or technique leads to why
trigger technique down the road create a
structured learning experience to
introduce people to many different
techniques as early as possible
create a clear learning track and work
through tricks and techniques in an
intuitive fashion to make the journey as
friendly as possible to beginners and
people who really need the guidance
number two emphasize body movement as
early as possible there are plenty of
examples of tricks that are accessible
to beginners that engage their full body
and can integrate with dance i want
people's flow to look and feel good as
soon as possible number three teach in
an integrated fashion learn transitions
as you're learning the tricks build
combos at every step of the journey to
make the tricks and techniques you're
working with feel holistic rather than
separate those of you who are familiar
with my channel may be asking
well didn't you kind of already do this
at the beginning of the pandemic with
your quarantine series and the answer is
yes i tried to but social media isn't a
great platform to do this kind of work
with for one thing the algorithms on
youtube and instagram are built around
keeping your interest rather than
building a good learning environment
finding one of those videos doesn't mean
that you'll find the others because the
platform
might suggest something totally
unrelated next and we wind up right back
in the territory of an unstructured
learning environment for another
tutorials on social platforms are built
around triggering specific keywords
individual tricks that somebody may be
looking for rather than giving people an
entire course to work with
lots of techniques involved in learning
poi don't actually result in easily
searchable terms now all that said i
still stand by that series as having a
great learning track and i hope having
introduced a lot of people to the arts
if you're curious and want to check it
out i'll leave a link down in the
description or up in the cards if you're
watching on youtube so after a lot of
consideration i've come to the
conclusion that in order to create the
learning environment that i want to see
i'm going to need to create it myself
but i'm going to need your help to get
there i've already outlined what i think
would be a good approach to teaching
somebody poi technique starting from
scratch all the way up to intermediate
spinning but
i need some people to playtest it i need
to see where people get stuck and
whether the pieces actually line up the
way that i think they do to that end i'm
going to be teaching weekly live
streaming classes starting on tuesday
august 9th these will be me workshopping
the material in four or five week
increments and they will be available to
view even after the class ends so even
if you aren't able to make the class
itself during the live stream you can
still view the lesson and give me
feedback on the material within it you
can sign up for this or any future
online units i'll be streaming over at
crowdcast.io
drexfactorpoi and this isn't just going
to be a passive tool either if you're
present for the lesson i can pull you up
on screen and give you direct feedback
if you're running into any problems it's
pretty nice ultimately the plan is that
once i've perfected this material i'll
use it to create a permanent course that
will be available over at my learning
site at learn.drexfactor.com
so if you're coming upon this video much
later you might want to check there too
i think we have the potential to bring
more poi spinners into this world and
more kinds of poi spinners as well
i think we can give people better tools
to navigate the frustrations of learning
poi help them get more comfortable with
inhabiting their bodies and give them
the pieces they'll need for long-term
success in the art no matter how long
they're a part of it i think that this
art can become more accessible more fun
and more beautiful
and i'd like to help make that happen
would you like to join me i would
certainly love the company once again to
sign up to go on this journey with me
head on over to crowdcast.io
drexfactorpoi i'll see y'all on there
soon help me get more people on board
for this experiment please make sure to
like comment share and subscribe to help
other people find this video tell your
friends pretty please
[Music]
this video and these projects would not
be possible were not for the kind
support of all of my wonderful
supporters on patreon including these
awesome folks who are signed up as my
flow patrons they along with the people
listed down in the description make this
video and all the videos on this channel
possible thank you one and all for your
support
if like me you would like to see more of
the world learning the potential of
their brains and their bodies by
spinning poi you can support me in that
mission by heading on over to
patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up
there you can get access to a host of
awesome rewards such as getting to see
your name in the credits or getting a
special poi lesson delivered to your
inbox every week that is available only
to my patreon supporters go give that a
look and i hope you sign up thanks in
advance if you'd like to check out that
playlist of tutorials i made early on in
the pandemic to get a rough idea of the
learning path that i'd like to take i'll
link to it down in the description as
well as up on screen if you are watching
on youtube
and of course the algorithm also thinks
that you'll like this top video so let's
see if youtube got the hint that you
want to learn some more and sends you to
a tutorial shall we
thank you so much for watching make sure
to get out and flow today and i'll see
you with a brand new video on wednesday
peace